[Music]
thank you very much and welcome to you
all great you're all here and the
Saturday morning in the big room the
next 30 minutes will be we will be
looking at sound we were just being
introduced my name is Julian fights MA
I'm here together with my colleague well
to Deventer we both work for I canna
lytx where we help clients with data
signs a machine learning this can mean
different kind of fields which means we
constantly have to acquire new domain
knowledge and at the moment we're doing
a project on audio classification for
urban sounds and we thought it would be
nice to share with you some of the
things we learned classifying noise
pollution is a growing area of research
there are there are a few public data
sets containing urban sounds decays 2019
is running at the moment and we started
experimenting with urban sound 8k to
learn something about how do you
classify sound a lot of cities have
noise conducts so for example there are
rules when you you can only operate a
jackhammer in weekdays or people are
responsible for the noise their dog
makes
or well does these are some of the
categories you see some of the classes
you see here most of the sound events
are 4 seconds long and to compare people
get an accuracy of 82% to recognize in
these 4 seconds seconds what what event
is in in the clip so computer vision
image classification has gotten a lot
better the last couple of years things
to convolutional neural networks and of
course more data more computing power
actually what what Tesla is doing with
computer vision at the moment for
autonomous driving is quite amazing
in a misclassification you try you see
you have an image and you try to
classify which object is in the image
and for sounded would be maybe more like
video where where different things
happen in succession but what we do is
we take an event a very very short clip
of audio
containing an event and then we try to
classify this event so this presentation
is about classification rather than
detection so what does the raw data look
like
I'm good luck with this here you see an
example of an audio event I don't know
if somebody can tell what's being shown
here this is what you look when you zoom
in now one thing to notice that we we
normalized all the samples so the
maximum amplitude is one if the sound is
working I would try to we're gonna
listen what's actually in here so there
is the sound of a siren and emmalin's or
a police car but there's also a lot of
background noise the question is how
we're going to tackle this problem and
to solve this we will switch to a
different representation we make use of
a Fourier transform you take a small
window in time and then you map it to
the frequency domain and you look for
every frequency bin how much energy
there is in this bin the the window we
use for the Fourier transform we used is
about between 20 milliseconds and 85
milliseconds so there's a few things you
have to consider how long are you going
to take this window and also we used
overlap we used 50% overlap and 75%
overlap so that's the length in the hop
length
and then we make a mel spectrogram which
is a power density spectral density
where you sample points on equally
spaced time and frequency and this
frequency we do on the mel skill which
is a log logarithmic scale and it lets
you compare sounds it's it's comparable
to what the human hearing does this is
an example of the same thing we just
listened to for it's the siren and the
mel spectrogram of a siren you can see
the siren in the middle and in the lower
part of the image you see the noise so
let's look at it again and here and
listen so you can see this the the tone
actually going up and down to make these
spectrums we use lis browser which lets
you handle audio files you can load in
an audio file we used a sample rate of
24 kilo Hertz for the audio files and
then you can convert it into a mel
spectrogram there's a few parameters you
have to tune there's the number of male
bands and this this will translate into
the vertical dimension of the image and
then you have the length of the fourier
window and also the hop size which
translates into the horizontal dimension
and this is what you end up with this is
these are the pictures we've we feed
into the neural net one thing to notice
which is different from images is that
the X's have different meaning so on on
the horizontal axis we have time and on
the vertical axis we have frequency and
this turns out to be sometimes it's it's
important to keep in mind
your picture to show the influence of
the free a window if you take a bigger
window you have more information in the
frequency domain but then you end up
with less time bins so it's a trade-off
between a high-resolution in frequency
or or in time this can be a hyper
parameter of your model but it means if
you change this parameter also the input
of your know neural net changes here you
see examples of mel spectrograms these
are all taken from urban 8k so these are
the pictures we fed into the neural net
we also make use of another type of
features so normally an image has a red
blue and green input channel so we had
the Mel spectrogram in the first channel
in the red Channel and we will add we
added a second feature channel like
behind it with the same dimensions Libre
Libre has a delta feature this is a
local estimate of the derivative and
this this may contain extra information
which which isn't captured in a mailgram
and we found that that using the Delta
features it improved things a little bit
the accuracy went up a few percent using
the the Delta features so then the input
shape is the is the number of Mel bands
by the number of time means times two
this is what goes into the neural net
here you see examples of the Delta
features so this also contains some
extra information some differences with
normal images sound and images do not
accumulate in the same manner if the ha
duck and the picture of the hot dog if
the horik lies on the table it hides
part of the table but if a police car
with a siren passes it mixes with the
street noise
so in the mail in the mail gram on the
right we just looked at one pixel can
belong to different sources on the left
you see clean signal you also see the
harmonics of the of the siren so there's
a few waves which show the harmonics
there is a way to make use of this
transparency and it's called between
class learning instead of feeling the
network the sound of a dog or the sound
of a cat we feed it but part cat part
dog so we pick two random training
examples and then we meet we mix them
with a random factor and so yeah for
example you have the the meow of a cat
and the bark of a dog and then in the in
the lower picture you see the mixture of
the two and wait a factor of 0.7 and the
label becomes 70% dark 30% cat actually
what we did is oh maybe I should say we
can do this linear combination because
we normalized the the audio files and
what we did is we took a linear
combination of the male spectrograms
which makes it easy to use in the
generator so you taken you take a random
male Specter gram multiplied with a
random factor and then you take a second
male spectrogram multiplied by one minus
the factor and you do the same with
labels and this helps quite a lot it's a
form of data augmentation and we found
it when we were making the model deeper
so when we had a more powerful model the
the nine the nine pound over 8000
samples from urban 8k was just not
enough data so we needed the
augmentation and between class learning
improve the results by a few percent
what more data augmentation can you do
so we looked at between clouds learning
you can also intentionally add
background noise a third one is time
stretching or compressing this this
didn't prove very effective it can
improve the some classes the accuracy on
some classes but it hurt performance and
other classes so let's let look at the
the last two
there's pitch shifting in the image the
whole signal moves up or down a little
bit we browser has a has a feature for
this to to pitch shift your features and
we found that working with three
different kind of pitch shifts improved
our results over no augmentation this is
this is from a very recent paper in this
augmentation you randomly block some
frequency bands and some time bins and
the position and the width of the band
is randomly chosen and this is very
effective in that it turns an
overfitting problem into an under
fitting problem we actually had to
remove all the drop out layers from the
network because the effect was so severe
you can think of it as as preventing the
model from for example learning that a
certain class always needs three
harmonics so this this is a technique we
didn't experiment with it a lot but but
it it is it looks promising other
differences if you have a doc in the
lower part of the picture and you move
the doc it's still a dog but
but it's the same pattern in a mail
spectrogram if you move it to a
different position it can be a
completely different thing on the left
you see in an engine that's idle and on
the right it what more or less the same
pattern is a metro passing so what is
going to tell you a little bit about how
we make use of this property in the
network okay yeah I'm gonna take over
from here and we're going to look at at
how we can structure the network to make
full use of that property of sounds that
it really matters on which frequency bin
on which vertical location of the of the
image or the or the feature set where
we're looking at so first a little bit
about max pooling probably to do a lot
of you a technique that you that you use
it's very common in in image recognition
networks and what it actually does it
discards spatial information which is
usually a good thing because it's it
really helps in in reducing the
computational load on your on your model
it makes it it makes it a lot smaller so
what it what it does for people that
don't know it it takes small squares of
of the feature set and it just takes the
maximum of each of the squares and it
puts into a new into a new vector so it
reduces the it yeah it reduces the
number of parameters it reduces the data
average pooling works kind of the same
and has the same effect in in terms that
it reduces the spatial information but
this is something that we we don't
necessarily want in in audio because it
does matter when when a certain pattern
emerges on a higher frequency or on a
lower frequency you could mean it can
mean a total different thing so this is
a part of a of a normal convolutional
Network we have a shape coming in the
first one first ones would be
the frequency or in a normal Network it
would be the X or the Y where we have to
have the time coming in and we have the
channels so only two channels that was
Delta and and the male spectrograms in
our case we have convolutional layers
few of them stack together
and we end up with a with a vector that
has a lot of channels and just limited
amount of spatial information yeah we
start with a with a with a pretty large
time window so it also remains we have
32 positions left on on the on the time
window there then there's a global Max
pulling done and we only end up with the
shape of 128 yeah data points then comes
the the dense layers and in a soft max
to eventually come up with a with a
classification so this is what what we
would normally do and this also works on
own sounds it works quite well actually
but there is a slightly better way and
that's doing this so instead of doing
the global max pooling we only do a max
pooling over the time dimension so we
we're going to skip all the time
information but we're going to keep the
frequency information and we're going to
keep it by just using a flatten instead
of the global mixed pooling or or global
average pooling so we end up with a
bigger shape that still contains the
frequency information and the dense net
and that the dense layers can I can make
use of that and yeah exploit the fact
that it's that it knows where it's
actually happening so this is this is
interesting it's yeah it's it it adds a
few percent to the performance so next
thing what we what we did is it's an
idea that also comes from from from
image image classification from from
visual computing and that's that's
something that is inspired by the
inception modules you probably heard of
the inception Network and these ideas
work also quite well we have a couple of
different filters with different
dimensions in
case it's not really a symmetric filter
but it's a it's a somatic filter so it's
a little bit bigger on the on the time
dimension it's something that you can
that you can play with and for the rest
it's a pretty standard inception
inception model that is yeah designed to
be computational computationally
efficient so you can build a little bit
deeper networks the same ideas we also
tested some ideas from from ResNet with
residual connections and also these
ideas work pretty well on the sound data
so also adds that's a few percent there
now of course our network consists of
multiple of these inception modules
stacked upon each other just as you
would do with normal convolutional
layers there's another way of exploiting
the fact that that the vertical location
or frequency being matters you could
also do something else that is a little
bit similar to the thing we saw before
with the max pooling but now it has a it
has a somewhat different effect so what
we do we split the image in in this case
in three sections the high frequency mid
frequency and low frequency sections and
then we retrain separate networks for
each of them so we have a separate
network for high frequencies with a few
yeah exception or in in spectrum module
stack together and we have them photo
for other frequency bands too in the end
we do the flatten trick as we seen
before and we do a concatenation it's
still in the same in the same network so
we can train it in one in one model in
one go and it's in it and we have the
standard dense networks at the end so
what this does it actually says there
could be other patterns and other things
happening in the higher frequencies that
we don't see in the lower frequencies
and if there would be the same they will
mean a different thing so you really
exploit the fact that these are very
different things going on in these in
these frequency bands so you can do with
a lot of with a lot less with a lot less
filters so it makes it computationally
more more efficient so to summarize
what we did what we do for sound
specificness we did the flattened layer
we have the in spectrum inception like
modules and we have to split frequency
bands we added to that some batch
normalization and some inner activations
to yeah to make the model perform a
little bit better so how does this fit
in the whole process because this is
just a model that we've talked about to
do full audio event detection we also
need some kind of detection of an audio
events and this is well it's not done
using machine learning it's just simple
peak detection if it's above a certain
threshold then it means we have an
interesting sound and interesting loud
sound that we want to classify that gets
a feed into the network which create the
mel spectrogram and the pre-processing
we have the the model that we talked
about and we have as a output to
classify the event so this is actually
how it all fits together so main
takeaways we've seen and computer vision
techniques were pretty good on sound you
can make mel spectrograms as a as a
proper representation to make it
two-dimensional to make it work sound
however has some differences I mean it's
transparent it add up its adds up
differently the frequency position
matter so we can exploit that fact and
the last thing well we've seen a lot of
different ideas I mean they all work
individually if they add up they also
work but there is kind of a limits to
that so there are many many ways to
accomplish good performance on these on
these networks so these are a couple of
ideas that you can try and it might work
better or or worse on your own data sets
well in the in in the summary of this
talk we promised to talk about detective
emotions also in customer contact
sensors because this is an other domain
that we've used the same techniques for
I don't think we have a lot of time to
cover this but I'll walk you through the
basics so what we do with emotion
detection is that it actually works as a
as a feedback mechanism when an agent in
a call center environments
has interactions with a customer you
have emotions as a as a feedback are you
doing well are you helping your your
client or is he becoming more and more
unhappy so these are some of the basic
emotions that that you can experience
and if you add a computer into the mix
that supports the agent you also need
some kind of feedback because if you're
like proposing knowledge base articles
for example to an agent to give to the
customer we also need some feedback
mechanism so you can have the feedback
mechanism also for the machine okay
well given given this but what can you
do what can you do with this as a
concrete example in a in a customer
contact center for example you can do
statistics on on different different
agents some people will have happier
customers on average than other people
and maybe if if somebody makes the
clients angry all the time maybe they
need some training so it also helps with
that because we know from each
conversation and in many cases those
conversations are recorded which ones
went south with once we're really bad so
we can we can easily look up in the
database which which conversations to
cut some emotional contact and use that
for training to listen to it again
together with the agent and see where we
can we can where we can improve
conversation for for a live dashboard
there's also some possibilities how are
we doing as a team as a as a contact
center team are we making people happy
today or not happy what is happening and
also some some live assistance in case
conversation goes really bad supervisor
can be alerted or you can give some
other interventions so this is what we
what we use it for the the pipeline is
roughly whether the pipeline is actually
a little different than than than the
soundtrack in the sound event detection
the sound event detection you can use
the same techniques as we've talked
about before
I must say when we're talking about
speech there might be some specific
techniques that that that can help there
because it's a little bit different
domain of course then then sounds in in
cities with what we're doing there is we
also take the contents of the
conversation into account we do a
speech-to-text transfer transcription we
use word embeddings and then you can
also stack a few convolutional networks
or Co volution or layers together
go get the naiton at the end and we have
a classified emotion as an adwords so
this is more in a in a research stage
this this this pipeline but the basic
techniques are are about the same so
yeah this is